Another thing Dr. Bright is not allowed to
do at the Foundation: Dr. Bright is not permitted
to assign the designation “Over 9000”
to any anomalies.
Dr. Bright is to be reminded that first of
all, the SCP Foundation does not track the
“power levels” of any of its anomalies,
as that is a completely subjective notion.
Adding “it’s over 9000” to official
Foundation documents is distracting, and confusing,
particularly when applied to entities like
SCP-999 who have no interest in combat.
Second of all, he should know that joke hasn’t
been relevant in over a decade, he’s embarrassing
himself and none of the new research assistants
even know what he’s referencing.
Finally, he’s not as good at doing the Vegeta
voice as he thinks he is.
Update your references, Dr. Bright!
You’re better than that!
…Maybe.